here is a shot from clifford the big red
dog before the beloved pup was added
with cg
to get the proper reference footage and
give the cast something to react to a
10-foot high practical version of
clifford was used and two puppeteers had
to carry the massive puppy through new
york city
that's just one of many movies that came
out in 2021 that involved risky car
stunts innovative camera work and a few
creature performers
after many previous out of this world
stunts
the latest fast and furious installment
took it to another level with magnetized
cars
the team had to create a magnetization
effect with very little cgi
stunt coordinator andy gill used
customized cars with hidden ramps
locking mechanisms and cables to give
the appearance of magnets pulling and
releasing other vehicles
[Music]
and for this scene when the cars speed
by store-lined city streets appliances
actually flew through the store windows
each appliance had an attached tube
filled with compressed air
when carefully cued they were launched
at the cars one by one while whizzing by
strategically placed extras
whether it was dancing on the wall a
huge pool musical number or making these
heads bob practically in the hair salon
filmmakers found innovative ways to
bring the award-winning musical in the
heights to the big screen
for the song when the sun goes down nina
and benny sing and dance on the side of
a building in washington heights but
neither of the actors wore safety
harnesses that's because the crew built
a giant replica of a brick wall fire
escapes included and rotated it 90
degrees to give the illusion of the
gravity-defying romance
the scene was filmed in front of a green
screen and the george washington bridge
and nyc sky were added afterward
in disney's live-action cruella costume
designer jenny bevin was tasked with
creating 47 different yet dramatic looks
for emma stone's lead character
like this dress worn when cruella makes
a surprise entrance from dumped rubbish
as she hops on the back of the garbage
truck
the dress reveals a 40-foot train made
from the baroness's discarded collection
of gowns the train was so long and
difficult to move in it couldn't
actually be worn on to set so production
had to attach it when the cameras cut
away from cruella but right before the
final exit and reveal
[Music]
this dress that accompanied this
military jacket had to be enormous
enough to trap the baroness's car but
light enough for stone to wear
chief pattern cutter kristen fletcher
and her team had to cut out
5060 petals which were later stitched on
by hand
and what about this climactic moment
when the baroness pushes cruella off the
balcony but her skirt transforms into a
life-saving parachute they tried their
hand practically but ultimately the
parachute dress had to be designed using
cgi
ready yeah almost 30 years after the
original space jam the long-awaited
sequel finally arrived
hundreds of artists collaborated to put
a new stamp on the live action animated
classic and bring the 2d looney tune
squad into a 3d world
real-life basketball stars were also
converted to 2d and 3d characters
with the many ambitious layers and
textures plus a hand-drawn approach
creating just one of those hybrid scenes
took nearly a year they also used motion
capture to get the animated characters
to play basketball
for the virtual basketball court
showdown a massive mocap stage was built
measuring 120 000 cubic feet utilizing a
setup with over 100 cameras
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the beloved pup from the children's book
and cartoon clifford the big red dog
came to life in the 2021 live-action
adaptation this required a big red
puppet
puppeteers rowan mcgee and john
riddleberger took on the physically
demanding task of carrying clifford for
eight to 14 hour days taking a break
every 70 minutes is that enough for the
dog
and dog exit frame
so in some scenes the puppeteers used
gimbals
instead like in this scene when
clifford's young owner gets on for a
ride she was really climbing a ladder to
sit on a gimbal with springs and wheels
hidden crew members pulled the gimbal to
move as the dog would and a hidden cable
attached to the actor kept her safe
[Music]
all right here we go guys be careful and
action m night shyamalan needed the
beach to be the villain in the movie old
so the team had to make playa el valle
in the dominican republic intense and
ominous that's where these fake
mountains come in production designer
nam and marshall and crew actually built
these mountains to create a sinister
presence after taking photographs and
measurements of the site in el valle
marshall returned to california to build
their model of the design since the
beach already had a rock wall marshall
blended theirs to it by using plaster
scaffolding foam paint and sand
at one point a hurricane even destroyed
the unfinished set but in the end they
managed to complete the 32 foot tall 900
foot wide wall
to blend it even more seamlessly the
visual effects team used photographs of
the natural rock to recreate various
textures on the surface
actor bob odenkirk reinvented himself
physically for his role in the action
film nobody odenkirk is known for
playing one of tv's most famous lawyers
in breaking bad and better call saul
very much a non-action role
typically actors train for four to six
weeks for action films but the 59 year
old comedian trained in martial arts for
two years with john wick and atomic
blonde stunt performer daniel bernhardt
you can see bernhardt in this scene
playing one of his attackers
even while filming better call saul
odenkirk continued to perfect his skills
in an albuquerque mixed martial arts gym
and the first glimpse of this payoff
happens in this fight scene which
happens on a real bus
the bus was made stunt friendly with
hidden padding on the floor and in the
seats and odenkirk did most of the
all-out brawl without a stunt double in
the end this bloody six-minute scene
took three nights to film
in reminiscence hugh jackman plays a
private investigator who uses a machine
to navigate his clients memories
but this water tank and these memory
projections in the machine were actually
created without a green screen visual
effects supervisor bruce jones worked
with director lisa joy to devise a way
for the actors to interact with the
memory seamlessly walking around the
moving pieces of footage on the set
the memories were filmed ahead of time
then projected onto a very thinly meshed
hollow gauze screen stretched into a
cylinder 320k projectors were needed to
map the moving images onto the circular
screen and the mocap cameras moved in
sync with the actors around the screens
keeping the illusion of a hologram
no time to die had one of the longest
pre-credit james bond openings clocking
in at over 20 minutes and with lots of
in-camera effects it was no easy feat
the action sequence was shot on location
in matera and used ten aston martins
for this scene the crew planted squibs
to replicate bullet impacts timed
perfectly with the car's movements
approximately 200 pellets were fired at
the car windows which were layered with
a special polycarbonate plastic so they
wouldn't shatter and this jump
was no green screen a stunt driver went
exactly 60 miles per hour up a 25-foot
ramp and jumped 12 feet in the air to
make the impressive landing it took four
takes to get the shot they needed
for the french dispatch wes anderson and
the production team created the
fictional french town of anui sur blase
by adding their own touch to the real
city of ongolem located in the southwest
of france
as anderson frequently does in his films
the crew relied on hand-crafted sets and
practical elements shot in camera
they constructed foreground buildings
and scaffolding that could twist and
turn for the camera added original
banners and signs to store walls
and built cafe fronts and trees even
freeze frames were recreated by having
actors keep still while objects hung in
mid-air
but not all the imaginative moments were
captured completely in camera
[Music]
in the film's prison riot sequence
benicio del toro's wheelchair shatters
mid-air
to achieve this effect green suit
performers held each part separately in
the air to precisely manipulate the
wheels
mirror shots are notoriously difficult
to film without the camera being seen
last night in soho had the added
challenge of having one character eloise
on one side and a different character
sandy on the other
the production design team built a
double lobby set so sandy and eloise
could follow each other in the mirror
it got more complicated when other
actors were in frame like in this shot
when jack joins eloise in front of the
mirror
that is actor matt smith's actual
reflection in a real mirror but it's
been cut in half on the other side is
sandy in front of a green screen vfx
later adjusted her background to match
perhaps the most physically taxing trick
comes during this elaborate mirrored
dance sequence the two actors had to
prep for weeks and work with a movement
coach to make sure not a single eye line
was off nor body movement unmatched
then to capture it all a steadicam
operator referred to on set as the human
motion control had to shoot every
mirrored shot the exact same way
in army of the dead the zombie tiger
valentine may have stolen the show
the vfx team based valentine on a white
tiger in florida which they later found
out was owned by carol baskin of
netflix's tiger king documentary
the team recorded and studied the animal
to nail down the proportions movement
and light for the zombie version later
they created the emaciated look with old
dried blood stains and a missing eye to
blend it in with the post-apocalyptic
environment
a stunt person in a green suit stood in
for eyelines and in the interactive
scenes and for the scene of the tiger
mauling martin cables were used to throw
him around as if the tiger was swinging
him with his jaws
three
two
run
action
the mcu blockbuster black widow was
filmed in multiple cities across the
globe
but the most visually stunning chase
scene was captured in budapest
production filmed for two weeks in the
city with motorcycles and armored
vehicles speeding wildly through city
streets special effects teams built some
of the large taskmaster tanks you see
here and a total of four bmws were
destroyed in the process with one
exploding in the air on a real budapest
street
the opening scene of a quiet place part
2 raised the stakes of its predecessor
by showing the character's first
encounter with the monsters the chaotic
sequence was done with very few cuts
this was especially tricky for the
moment when emily blunt's character
evelyn has to quickly reverse her car as
a mangled bus heads towards them at over
40 miles per hour
a series of cameras were mounted inside
and out of evelyn's car with a custom
biscuit rig
at the top of the car a stunt driver
operated the vehicle as blunt pretended
to be in control
hold on everybody
the bus sequence in chongqi raised the
stakes higher than many marvel fights
before it by setting the action on a
moving surface
it took a month to film this nearly
seven minute sequence
the actors all went through intense
training for the film's hand-to-hand
combat and simulu did a good portion of
the stunts by himself for the scenes
that show the outside of the bus several
real buses were filmed driving through
san francisco
two separate buses were shipped from
california to sydney australia to be
deconstructed and used in a blue screen
studio both were suspended one on a
15-foot high six-axis gimbal for the
leaps twisting and turning and the other
slightly off the ground to simulate the
bus shaking and general driving shots
ghostbusters afterlife stayed true to
the original by bringing back the terror
dog and the original's cutting-edge
creature effects work
afterlife's crew decided to use as
little cgi as possible building their
monsters from scratch the practical
terror dog ultimately weighed
450 pounds thanks to its mechanized
motors called servos which allowed
specific movements
the monster's face alone had 21 servos
controlled by puppeteers to create
detailed movements like blinking and
sniffing
these servos were crucial to making the
character look as real as possible
but traditional cables also helped
create convincing movements
the dog's leg in this scene used just an
isolated leg controlled by cables the
puppeteer could wear the leg on his arm
manipulating its movement
and because the leg was so big cables
helped move its ankles and toes where
the puppeteer's real arm couldn't reach
[Music]
you